vielleicht fragen erst frau lindner wie
überrascht waren sie von diesem
politischen knall von links der rückzug
von herrn leuten von der afg spitze und
dann auch komplett austritt aus der
partei vor wenigen tagen ich glaube man
muss das 2 teilen von der tatsache an
sich war ich eigentlich nicht überrascht
vom zeitpunkt war ich überrascht wie
vorher
akku wenig hinweise darauf gegeben hatte
und das ist auch das worüber ich mir die
ganze zeit jetzt auch gedanken gemacht
haben was ist eigentlich passiert es
sind 109 thema gewesen zwischen dem 11
oktober woher wollten gesagt hat er
tritt nicht noch mal an er kandidiert
nicht noch mal als coo parteisprecher
das war insofern erwartet worden als
dass wir wollten sich das im wahlkampf
offen gehalten hatte ich vermute um das
nicht in den wahlkampf reinzutragen dann
quasi zwei wochen abgewartet nach der
bundestagswahl dann die mitteilung so
ich trete nicht mehr an 109 tage dann
kommt der 28 januar und dann fragt man
sich ja tatsächlich schon wie ist dieser
tag abgelaufen ist ja wollten dann
morgens aufgewacht hat festgestellt
ich bin cool vorsitzender einer in
teilen
rechtsradikalen partei das möchte ich
nicht mehr sein ich rufe die ard
kollegen an und dann 14 uhr
war eigentlich bundesvorstandssitzung
der afd dann können sie sich da mal
darüber gedanken machen meine ehemaligen
weggefährten mittlerweile glaube ich
eigentlich dass
und jemand eine gewichtige rolle dabei
spielt das ist ein schreiben vom 3
januar kommt von einer kanzlei die im
auftrage des bundesamtes für
verfassungsschutz arbeitet gerichtet an
das verwaltungsgericht in köln was am 8
9 märz verhandelt ob die afg zum als
gesamtpartei zum verdachtsfall
hochgestuft wird oder nicht ob darüber
auch öffentlich gesprochen werden kann
und mein eindruck war eigentlich dass
mit diesem schreiben was noch einmal
zusätzliche belege für diese hochstufung
geliefert hat dann hören wollten auch
klar diese beobachtung lässt sich nicht
mehr abwenden ich möchte damit nichts
mehr zu tun haben weil was man jetzt
beobachten kann auch zum beispiel mit
dem auftritt hier in dieser sendung oder
auch mit interviews hd zdf im öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk bei den kollegen
von der pioneer also das ist ja eine
ganze latte die man mittlerweile
bewundern kann dass wir wollten sehr
hart einem reputationsmanagement
arbeitet also das heißt dass er sehr
darauf bedacht ist jetzt quasi von
diesem sinkenden tanker von diesem
sinkenden schiff was er sechseinhalb
jahre lang mit geleitet hat sich zu
verabschieden und dann möglichst ja
unbefleckt
möglicherweise in einem entweder weitere
politische karriere vielleicht auch eine
weitere akademische karriere an der
hochschule in kehl dann starten zu
können weil ich kann mir vorstellen dass
die hochschule in kiel sicherlich nicht
sehr begeistert darüber ist wenn da
jemand kommt der dann als
parteivorsitzender einer partei angehört
hat die tatsächlich dann auch als
verdachtsfall beim verfassungsschutz
geführt wird das so sehe ich diese
diesem moment ist das ist dass der
zusammenhang in münster gibt deswegen
ganz glückliche fügung dass ich hier bin
und das aufklären kann
holländer sie in das hat mit dem
schreiben vom briten januar nichts zu
tun und mit der vsg beobachtung nichts
zu tun es hat auch nichts mit mit ganz
aktuellen geschehnissen aus dieser woche
zu tun sondern kann das hier aufklären
meine entscheidung diesen schritt zu
gehen
die ist langfristig gereift das war für
mich ein sehr schmerzhafter prozess an
dem
ich manche schlaflose nacht oder indem
ich manche schlaflose nacht verbracht
habe
um für mich festzustellen es geht nicht
mehr und die entscheidung ist knapp zwei
wochen vorher gefallen dass wir sind an
diesem tag gemacht habe aber ich gemacht
weil ich an dem tag sowieso in berlin
war und weil klar ist das wird ein sehr
hohes medieninteresse geben da kann ich
nicht darauf immer in meinem dorf in
süddeutschland sitzen haben sich schon
in dem tag in berlin zu gehen weil darum
habe ich diesen tag mir ausgesucht haben
das so gemacht
die die geschichte ist die ich musste
mich eigentlich muss ich mir zwei fragen
beantworten der eine frage gebe ich
diesem projekt alternative für
deutschland als alternative
noch eine zukunft und die zweite frage
ist
gewesen kann ich den weg den diese
parteien nimmt mitgehen und ich habe mir
in einem langen prozess beide fragen
schließlich final mit nein beantwortet
und wenn man an dem punkt angelangt ist
dann gibt es gar nichts anderes ich habe
diesen so ein bisschen aus der distanz
und auch begegnungen hier diesen prozess
dann hat man so ein bisschen mehr
erahnen können nichtsdestotrotz
direkt gefragt warum sind sie nicht nur
so lange drin geblieben sondern haben
diese partei und das war für diese
partei mittlerweile steht ja immer
wieder verteidigt da wir können mal kurz
rein am 17 märz des vergangenen jahres
als noch kein jahr her da saßen sie
hilft mit cem özdemir wenn sie auch
bestens kennen und der bafin sinngemäß
so was vor dass sie der der
parlamentarische arm vom rassismus usw
sein und sagte schauen sie sich mal an
was der zentralrat der juden über sie
sagt und so weiter und ihre replik
darauf es war sehr interessant und haben
uns jetzt extra noch mal raus gezogen
war folgende
idee ist eine bürgerlich konservativ
freiheitliche partei und wenn sie dahin
abdriftet wohin er zu mir sagt dass wir
es längst sein was ich vehement
zurückweisen dann ginge es nicht mehr
dann verdiente diese partei auch nicht
gewählt zu werden aber da sind wir nicht
da sind wir nicht okay frau aber dann
kommen wir auch nicht hin dafür sorge so
dafür sorgen dass sie sagen ist eine
bürgerlich konservativ freiheitliche
partei
das war immer mein ziel da wollte
glauben sie dass das dass die fdp vor
einem jahr war
dass sie da in der drift war war für
mich auch in sachen können sie sagen
hier sind die afg seine bürgerlich
konservativ freiheitliche partei wenn
sie abdriftet dann was ich vehement
zurück dann ging er es nicht mehr und
dann verdient dass dieser partei auch
nicht gewählt zu werden zu dem zeitpunkt
muss ihnen doch längst klar gewesen sein
auf welche reise diese partei ist es gab
in dieser partei immer und ich war
derjenige der es gesagt hat was mir
unglaublichen ärger eingetragen hat es
gab in dieser partei immer zwei parteien
in einer es gibt es gibt sie sogar heute
noch die bürgerlich-konservativ
freiheitlichen die grunde genommen aus
der aus der ersten ära der
entstehungsgeschichte der der partei
doch von denen sitzt doch da keiner mehr
wollte auch dass es noch eine ganze
menge dabei die sitzen nicht in der
ersten reihe weil sie sich das nicht
getraut haben ich war der der sich
getraut hat ich wollte das ursprünglich
gar nicht aber ich wurde dann 2015 essen
ist eine eigene geschichte ja ich habe
das dann aber schließlich gemacht und es
gibt die anderen die
völkische nationalistischen kurs sind
der für meine begriffe völlig schräg
sondern nicht geht und genau in diesem
spannungsverhältnis lebt diese partei
seid ja erneuten okay noch mal mit genau
diesen völkischen leuten jedoch extrem
lange gut gelaufen ich ehrlich haben sie
war eines der der weil wir gerade sehen
börnecke denn denn den parteiausschluss
von bern haben sie verhindert weil er
nicht geklappt hätte nicht weil ich
ihnen hier aus haben wollte ich habe mir
ein paar zähne asiaten okay wenn ich am
höchsten worum es sich erklären lassen
lasse ich sie was ich sie gerne sagen
sie ist einmal aber ich habe danach
direkt zwei fragen gut wenn ich einen
parteiausschluss verfahren anstrengen
und das hab ich habe etliche gemacht ich
hab so ein kallwitz gemacht wird sayn
wittgenstein mit gideon und vielen
anderen illegale rausgekriegt das war
oft auch kannte bei calvins das war
knappe geschichte es ist alles so
gekommen in dem hacker verein an gesagt
das geht hoch wahrscheinlich schief und
wenn ein pkv dann partei heraus dass das
schiefgeht dann
sind sie reduzierte und derjenige
ausgeschlossen werden sollte steht als
großer sieger da nichts ist fataler als
das darum habe ich davor zurückgescheut
dabei okay das war meine frage um das
erklärte meine frage okay wenn ihnen das
so klar war warum sie dann dass sich die
entscheidung getroffen einfach
auszutreten jetzt hätten sagen können
das was da geredet wird was der immer
wieder von sie obwohl er immer wieder
provoziert er auch jetzt wieder alles
für deutschland ja es ist eine erlösung
und da sind dann sieht das finden sie
unterirdisch oder nicht das ist komplett
unterirdisch und indiskutabel der mann
weiß ja was er sagt ja wenn der markt
nicht die hellste kerze auf vertraute
sein aber er ist geschichtslehrer und
das alles für deutschland heißt und dass
das netz an konzentration er hat am
zweiten februar diesen jahres im
erfurter landtag davon gesprochen dass
die impfpflicht dem holocaust verglichen
mit dem holocaust nicht mit menschen
versuchen vor dem holocaust verglichen
das ist immer noch glaubt ihm das aber
das macht er ja nicht erst seit gestern
hat er doch damals schon so gemacht
dieser mann über jahre hinweg
widerwärtige sachen gesagt weiß ich dass
ich mit einer die kenne ich besser damit
auch diesen flügel ihrer partei nicht so
alles viel bedeutet und dass nicht die
frage ist
jetzt tun das liegt nicht daran dass sie
plötzlich in den klassen haben dass eine
rechtsextreme partei deshalb kümmern sie
sich nochmals
darzulegen das liegt daran dass sie
keine machtperspektiven hatten in dieser
partei das ist keine frage von rückgrat
keine seitlichen anstoß seltsame eine
frage von macht und diese
machen nachdem sie das thema eine partei
geduldet haben die nimmt ihnen niemand
ab mal was sie nicht kümmern sie sich
immer irgendwie um die gewalt erfinder
in ihrer partei aber das war schon mal
hier und comcom
versuch ein bisschen sagt nicht zugleich
aber die frage ist doch sehr berechtigt
die frauen gerade frage ich sehr
berechtigt da müssen sie mich aber er
lernt ausreden lassen auch nicht
erklären ich habe sind wir uns schon mal
erklärt ich lasse aber ich mach das
nochmal zwei frage ich mache das gerne
noch mal ich bin ein herrlicher mensch
ich habe ihnen gesagt sind zwei parteien
in einer und ich wollte tatsächlich eine
bürgerlich freiheitlich konservative
alternative schaffen und ich habe diesen
versuchen länger ausgehalten als andere
ich habe 2018 gemerkt die geschichte
wird kritisch 2080 häuser treffen
käfertreffen letztes hab ich auch in
dieser sendung hier schon mal sagen und
dann habe ich den hebel um ungelenk
anfangs vorsichtig und dann sehr sehr
entschieden aber ich habe okay ich bin
vollständig ins risiko gegangen ich habe
mich ich habe für die flügel auflösung
gesagt okay jetzt raus sayn wittgenstein
reden wir glaubt das waren ja wirklich
nette geschichte ja überall bestehen
begeht an wusste ich jetzt merken und
das der punkt warum ich jetzt ausdrücken
das ist keine zukunft hat weil ich
letztlich ein feldherr ohne truppen war
ich mal so machtlos machtlos er machtlos
da habe ich ja kein problem mit ja ich
hole mir auch das hat jedoch einzig
räumt frank und frei kinder sich leisten
gescheitert bin in dem punkt danke ich
wollte ich bin das völlig abscheu nicht
sich sogar schön zu reden will
aufrichtig sein ich habe den versuch
gemacht diese partei auf einen
bürgerlich konservativen kurs zu bringen
und ich bin ja ein gescheiter hin als
ich gesehen habe ich bin darin
gescheitert und das krieg ich auch nicht
mehr repariert da bin ich gegangen so
was ich habe ich zwar länger als andere
und sie hat was man mir vorhält als in
ordnung ich habe frau sucht schon die
ganze zeit sie dürfen auch sofort von
lindner weil sie sich sehr intensiv auch
mit der elf die immer wieder beschäftigt
haben trotzdem eine frage noch es war
interessant sie sagten gerade beharrlich
was eine sehr positiv konnotierte
charaktereigenschaft ist wie ich habe
länger als andere ausgehalten das war
ein weißer können nicht in dem
zusammenhang mit theke denn sozusagen
das bild vermitteln eines märtyrers der
es an der seite von elke ausgehalten hat
das ist also nicht sie hätten damals
austreten können sie hätten sagen können
was auf den knall kriegst du jetzt das
mache ich nicht mehr mit das halte ich
eben gerade nicht mehr ich trete als
bundesvorsitzender zurück weil ich einen
durchgeknallten landesvorsitzenden habe
irlands ist ja nicht nur ein
durchgeknallter landes wo sitzen sondern
die große richtung dieser anteil dieser
landesvorstand nach 2019 haben
bundesparteitag eine 10 24 mehrheit
gehabt mit der habe ich alle diese dinge
durchgebrannt und das werde auch von
ländern
ich zurückweisen können das war anfangs
sehr erfolgreich und dann sind weil ich
diesen kampf sehr sehr hart geführt hat
und es war sehr schmerzhaft dann sind
mir meine leute von der stange gegangen
und dann habe ich keine mehrheiten mehr
gehabt exemplarisch und das hat viel
damit zu tun warum ich als parteichef
dann nicht mehr antrag helferich
helferich entscheidung habe ich sechs
acht vorgenommen sich dieses mal mit dem
kerner mit oder frau winter vielleicht
erklären sie ist ja es ist eine
interessante personalie interessante
personalie
sein anwalt aus nordrhein westfalen die
landesliste nordrhein-westfalen jetzt
2021 neu in den bundestag eingezogen ist
aber interessanterweise nicht teil der
bundestagsfraktionen er ist nicht
eingetreten nachdem auffällig geworden
ist durch formulierungen wie ich will
das freundliche gesicht des ns also
nationalist wir mussten ja der der auch
ns richter als seine politischen
vorbilder gesehen freisler unter anderen
auch die formulierung zusammenhang
betreuung zeichnet sich in diesem
internen chat als demokratischer
freifläche und wissenschaft preisblasen
blieb am krausen frei ist oder runter
jetzt vorgestern war vor drei tagen in
nordrhein westfalen zum land der
schiedsrichter gewählt das stellen sind
darstellen so eine mehr oder minder
bürgerlichen vorstand hin und dann
werden die diesen mann zum landes
schiedsrichter mit 52 prozent hätten
dann stimmt das ist ja interessant wie
viele innere distanz sie offensichtlich
ist von ihrer ehemaligen partei
aufgebaut haben weil auch wenn man jetzt
noch mal zurück geht an diesem punkt wo
wir eben war anfang 2000 21 da lag ja
schon das zweite gutachten das
verfassungsschutz sich über 1000 seiten
lang auf dem tisch die ard hat die
beobachtung nur dadurch verhindert über
juristische schritte aber es war völlig
klar der zustand dieser partei war
völlig klar nächster schritt 2021 war
april 2023
bundesparteitag in dresden
programmparteitag die afg gibt sich das
bundestagswahlprogramm und spätestens ab
diesem punkt ist dann perücke aus der
kulisse gekommen der lange zeit so was
wie ein parteitags phänomen war der sich
auf parteitagen kommen eingebracht haben
muss thüringen heraus agiert hat da ist
aus der kulisse getreten und hat dieses
bundestagswahlprogramm
in einer form mitgeprägt die einem
wirklich die spucke verschlagen hat und
die partei ist ihm gefolgt in ihren
mehrheiten und spätestens da wäre eine
möglichkeit gewesen zu sagen es ist
völlig klar wo diese wohin die reise
geht wohin die reise geht und hat sie
recht sagen was in diesem jahr 2018 wenn
sie jetzt sagen herr molten und das ist
das was ich ihn tatsächlich unterstelle
dass sie immer ein funktional
strategisches verhältnis zu diesen
rechten parteigliederungen hatten
das immer versucht haben diesen
sogenannten liberalen kurs zur
verfolgung auch im sinne einer wähler
stimmenmaximierung
nicht aus überzeugung sondern auch um
wählerstimmen ab zugreifen was haben sie
jetzt das ist politik der bürgerlichen
lager arbeitet politik immer nennt das
ist
bitte ganz kurz machen nach diesen
vorwürfen sagen sie sie haben zweifel
daran bekommen wie es dort zugeht
sie haben das vor allem damit begründet
ja wie dort gehandelt wurde wieso 20
performance vaters dort orden verliehen
wurden das dort fahnen getragen so dass
uns heute so aber was machen sie danach
sie fahren dann im september
2018 nach schnell ruder zum institut für
staatspolitik dort in die sommerakademie
halten eine halbstündige rede zum thema
europa und sagen dann am ende dieser
rede ja und sie möchten wieder für
europa antreten europa in ihrem sinne
verändern und bitten dann dort um die
unterstützung dieser leute schnell mal
kurz erklären ja genau dort den sachsen
anhalt ist sozusagen chiffre also wenn
man sagt schnell ruder meint man damit
das institut für staatspolitik
mittlerweile auch als
rechtsextremistisch beobachter verleger
check der verlierer wird kubitschek ist
dort der 2000 der mentor auf dieser
partei ist mentor von einigen in dieser
partei vor allem
hans thomas thiel schneider aus sachsen
anhalt ist dort aktiv der dann zum
beispiel aber auch im landtagswahlkampf
sachsen anhalt im vergangenen jahr dort
auf parteiveranstaltungen steht und dann
quasi mir kommt das vor wie der lehrer
seinen schülern dann sieht zb wie für
merseburg dann auftritt und ich glaube
das war auch der auftritt wo dann dieser
spruch alles für deutschland dann auch
gefallen ist was jetzt wiederum mit als
stellwerk der ort wo heute über den
das ist das geistige zentrum dieser
völlig nationalistischen strömen so da
haben sie auch gesprochen erinnert 2018
sie hat sogar das genaue datum sie haben
wir als unheimlich präzise ja da war ich
auf der durchreise zum landesparteitag
irgendwo im osten ich gerade in sachsen
anhalt auch und da hab ich das tor
gemacht habe eine kurze rede gehalten
die schwaben den knappen stunde da ich
habe das immer gemacht und den schuh
zieh ich mir nicht anders das war werden
jährlich bei götz kubitschek
vorbeigekommen sie glauben gar nicht wo
ich überall war ich habe alle partei
geht es nicht mehr
läuten das ist nicht irgendwo ist
einfach sie wollen ja ein ernstes diese
diese eine stunde die ich da einen
vortrag gehalten um mir das mal
anzuschauen und ich war nicht begeistert
von dem baden weiß gott nicht haben um
sie herum gebeten und sie sind dann und
das könnte man da könnte man die
zeitschiene vielleicht noch ein bisschen
verlängern november 2008 seine
aufstellung der europa liste unter
anderem in magdeburg dann später in
riesa
großartige zustimmung das heißt sie
konnten damit auch die zustimmung von
den extremen rechten teilen unter
anderem auch des flügels der partei
sichern ob dieses manöver dann stelle
oder was damit zu tun hat ich glaube ja
sie haben es immer schritt näher bei
haben definitiv genauso wie man gesagt
habe keine zeit damit mir die liste
ausgehandelt das sind alles messbar
gemacht ja ich würde auf hier sei der
punkt mit sie haben guten punkt mit
dresden im letzten frühjahr denn das war
für mich da fing mein abschied an und
zwar nicht wegen höcke interessiert mich
nicht mich interessiert es muss eine
luxuriöse position dafür dass er große
teile des musters knieproblemen wieder
ausreichend mich interessiert das
bundestagswahlprogramm und wenn da der
darin steht also der austritt
deutschlands als forderung aus der
europäischen union dann ist das ein weg
den ich mitgehen breit ich habe das wort
ergriffen ich habe massiv dagegen
geredet es ist trotzdem gegen meinen
willen abgestimmt worden und dann merkt
man dass sich da etwas programmatisch
verändert und dann merkt man auch das
kannst du nicht mehr mitgehen und dabei
ist mir ehrlich sein man wolle das ist
mir völlig
2018 kyffhäuser treffen auch so ein
symbolträchtiger
symbolträchtige veranstaltung fünf
häuser treffen 2080 waren 16 dabei 17
dabei 18 das letzte mal dabei da hab ich
gesagt ich nehme in der sekunde sie
haben in der eingangsrede nach dem
kurzen teil daraus vorbereitet haben sie
folgendes gesagt jetzt kommt das ganz
kurz
zum dritten mal in folge
auf dem großen jahrestreffen des flügels
und mit freude stelle ich fest dass das
anders als beim ersten mal inzwischen
ein hohes maß an selbstverständnis hat
so habe ich es mir immer gewünscht dafür
habe ich gearbeitet und so ist es
gekommen
es hat sich gelohnt dafür zu kämpfen
so kyffhäuser treffen und wir haben das
schon mal besprochen hier in der sich so
eingespielt genau dahin schon 100 werde
nirgends verein sich aber wichtig ist
die chronologie also minister auch fair
sein das war sozusagen vorher kurz
danach tritt kalbitz auf und sagt
folgendes genau der sich damals anhören
die glücksritter
sozialsystem imperialisten wollen wir
gar nicht integrieren wir wollen die gar
nicht integrieren wir wollen dir
emigrieren masseneinwanderung ist messer
einwandern
ich stelle mir das vor wie gründen seine
never come back airline und ich bin auf
dem flug nach irgendwo und ich bin ganz
sicher wir kriegen den flieger voll mit
den claudia roth den champs de mars und
wie sie alle heißen
denn eines
denn eines ist klar und
unmissverständlich wer deutschland nicht
liebt soll deutschland verlassen
[Applaus]
und ich weiß jetzt heller die
chronologie ist wichtig danach kam
übrigens circle das wurde noch kasseler
raum paar dinge rausgehauen und da habe
ich habe den versuch gemacht und dann
muss ich mit dem vorwurf leben ich habe
versucht diese strömung zu integrieren
ich habe sie anfangs unterschätzt habe
andere dinge nicht unterschätzt habe ich
sofort kapiert deswegen hab ich 2016
sogar die fraktion in stuttgart
gespalten weil ich gesagt habe ich setze
mich nicht mit einem antisemitischen
einer fraktion weil ich das sofort
verstanden habe bei denen habe ich
gedacht das ist eine harmlose harmlose
geschichte und das sagt 2016/17 das
waren so genannte freundes treffen auch
anders aus da wo das richtig krass und
glauben sie mir als ich im auto saß
unter wegfuhr gesagt die rede hätte
besser nicht gehalten denn was dann kam
das war genau das was sie was ihr da
gerade eingespielt haben und da hab ich
gesagt sehe ich ihn nehmen um zeigt dass
vorurteilen sicherlich das ergibt so 1
das passt überhaupt nicht zusammen also
weil dann es geht ja noch weiter in der
zeitlinie naja 2000 bis 2009 10 ein
interessantes jahr für die afd erst die
europawahl die so halbwegs nur die
eigentlich eher mittelmäßig ausgegangen
ist da konnte man die
kernwähler mobilisieren damals im mai
2009 10 so dann aber kam der herbst das
waren die drei wahlen in ostdeutschland
das war sachsen und brandenburg
sie sind aufgetreten in cottbus
tradierter juli führen für diesen
kalbitz dem gerade gesehen hatten sie
haben für kyle hines vorbereitet lasst
uns einmal kurz reinhören es ist
interessant dass gerade ansprechend wir
haben es da lasst uns einmal kurz
ein ziemlich harten rund als
spitzenkandidat
ja das nahtlos wert ein der den hier
schon viel zu lange regierenden kräften
im landtag in potsdam zu langer stachel
im fleische ist es ist wäre ich mit
meinen unterlagen bei der wind und ich
glaube das wird dann nach der wahl noch
viel mehr sein in welcher rolle auch
immer ein politik profi aber einer im
guten sinne das gibt es nämlich auch
denn er steht zwar klare inhalte und
kämpft gegen massive widerstände für die
bürger seiner wahlheimat hier in
brandenburg
haben heute das krieg ich nicht zusammen
sie sagten gerade ich bin nach hause
gefahren dachte nie wieder war sie
entsetzt waren über das was kalbitz ein
jahr vorher sagt und anja später stehen
sie bei der wahlkampfveranstaltung
ich muss ein stück weit als
parteivorsitzender wahlkampf machen und
da kann ich mich hinstellen und sagen
dass ich über andreas kalbitz erschrecke
der landwehr hat dafür gesorgt dass
kallwitz nicht mehr in der partei ist
belegen vom spiegel die nämlich sein
vorleben veröffentlicht haben und dabei
die leistung und das war gut eine lanze
den kollegen anzubieten also das sind
sie ja nicht drauf gekommen
da bin ich auch nicht von selber drauf
gekommen sondern ich habe mir das dann
sehr genau angeschaut und als das offen
lagen und das war für mich im januar 19
wenn wir schon
20 im januar 20 und dann habe ich bin
ich diesen weg gegangen und sie werden
vielleicht eine vage vorstellung haben
wie schwer das in der verstehen
ich will gar nicht mehr mitleid
noch mal ziemlich zulassung zum
verständnis normal also liebhäuser
treffen der redet da was er redet und
alia später treten sie bei ihm auch die
hoben ihn sogar sagen das ist einer im
guten sinne ja
noch mal dass eine wahlkampf situation
aber sie verstehen das selber nicht oder
doch ich verstehe das kann man jetzt
sogar nicht erklären
man müsste dann in die genauen termine
ein schauen und dann sehen sie dass ich
da sehr wenig termine macht aber mehr
bewusst sein das ist klar es geht dann
muss man da sagt die entscheidung heute
haben wir stellen das waren jetzt sagt
ich lasse mich das argument dass sie
also
sozusagen das spiel mitspielen müssen
wenn es ist eine entscheidung die sich
ein stück weit muss ein spiel das
verstehen sich so aber die entscheidung
auf diese bühne zu gehen und satz eins
zwei drei und vier zu sagen die treffen
sie ganz allein
das was mein land was soll ich da sagen
das nicht soll ich sollte ich da sagen
ich halte ich halte ihn ganz gab es eine
absolute mehrheit genossen das
entscheidung das kann ich nicht tun ok
ok habe ich eine letzte frage am morgen
eine letzte frage habe ich
sie haben sich ja immer so zu sagen als
dass bürger die bürgerliche stimme
innerhalb dieser partei ein bisschen
auch inszeniert und das war ja auch
gefährlich wenn einer wie sie sagen der
eloquente intellektuelle brilliante
professor wenn der das sozusagen
verteidigt für der teil dieser partei
ist dann ist das ja durchaus attraktiv
für den einen oder anderen wähler der
sonst vielleicht mit so unappetitlichen
gestalten wie es da auch gibt dies zu
tun haben möchte dass das ist ihr teil
der verantwortung und ich erinnere mich
ich sag ihnen waren das für mich gekippt
ist für jemanden der da von außen drauf
guckt ich habe irgendwann ich habe sie
wahrgenommen ich weiß auch das
allererste mal in einer sendung mit
frank plasberg hart aber fair und dachte
das war nicht völlig andere situation
sagte interessantes gespräch und der
kommt aus der wirtschaft des
interessanter mann und dieser selbe mann
sagt irgendwann plötzlich dieses links
rot grün schwarz war versiffte milieu
und feiert sich dann auch noch später
dafür in einem interview dass er das
quasi erfunden hat das habe ich nicht
verstanden da dachte ich da ist jetzt
auch mit herrn morgen irgendwas passiert
das war ich habe der senat zum
geflügelten wort analysiert das stand
überhaupt nicht in meinem rede skript
wir uns gesagt das geht zurück auf eine
äußerung von außenminister maß damals
der gesagt hatte die wollen ein anderes
deutschland und wenn ich das das
deutschland der grünen und der spd wird
das links-grüne das ist aber wollte ich
nicht aber es geht um die formulierungen
und der rewe dahingesagt nicht mehr also
die original formulierung mauserte
links rot-grün verseuchte 68er
deutschland das wollen wir nicht
jeder dieser rote man kann versichert
sind so weiter und dann habe ich im
nachgang gesagt man könnte auch versucht
sagen und damit meine ich etwas kommt
bestätigt stehen im ernst ich bin
stockkonservativ ich bin konservativ
freiheitliche was in diesem land
passiert schockiert mich zutiefst und
ich halte diesen satz so für ok zu
diesem satz stehe ich weil das es nicht
dass deutschland was ich möchte ich
möchte ich möchte ein bürgerliches
deutschland ich möchte ein
freiheitliches ich möchte ein
marktwirtschaftliches ich möchte eines
in dem kam odh live-version verstehen
haben richtig mir geht es nicht um die
position aber mir nein es geht um die
sprache es geht um die sprache ist um
diesen tabubruch plötzlich diesen sound
zu etablieren zuversicht links rot-grün
versucht dieses verächtlich machen er
schaut sich dafür zu feiern herr lanz
das ist das was hier muss man wirklich
differenzieren was was sie noch mehr an
position ist dass das geht man nach mit
nur die spiele sprache muss man auch mal
hart polemisch werden können kann man
bei mir hört jetzt fertig machen genau
das der punkt dass das wort da sie so
dass kein verächtlich machen ich
verachte niemand ich war ich habe völlig
andere positionen und ich lege ich
verachte sie nicht ich verachte airbag
nicht und frau werber und wie sie alle
heißen ich verachte sich jemand meister
den grünen oder sie treten
entschuldigung ich glaube nicht an
zurückgegangen er ist in der tat
verrückt ja das wird das garantiere ich
ihnen niemals passiert unternehmen die
mich aus sie verstehen
das ist wie das ganze gelaufen was man
geht für mich ist das kein verächtlich
macht dass er hatte polemik ja aber
nicht verächtlich machen ich habe aber
in jüngster zeit in der afg verächtlich
machen erlebt der hilfe der da oben
sagte ich ich ich verachte sie so
richtung berg runter das sind die der
sound in ähnlichen markt und noch
schlimmeres ist mir in brüssel wieder
fahren mit einem
menschen aus der delegation der ich
vorstand der sich da in ein widerlicher
weise äußerte über den gerade eben erst
verstorbenen präsidenten soli
das ist das ist menschlich sagte nach
dem tod dieses mannes über schrieb in
einem chat war es war ein interner chat
und ich hab da maximal und sofort
schnell interveniert er hat geschrieben
endlich ist das dreckschwein weg und das
über einen menschen der von neun stunden
verstorben ist das aber noch mal
mit der kurze antwort du wirklich nur
das interessiert mich nur noch machen
sie sich an dem punkt den vorwurf dass
sie sozusagen diese sprache nach
angebracht haben nein habe ich nicht das
ein anderer getan
definitiv